hello everyone and welcome to round 8 of
the 2018 bill chess festival it's yet
another opportunity for Magnus Carlsen
to even up to the score against his old
rival Peter Svidler as Peter Svidler is
one of those people who has a positive
score against Magnus Carlsen in
classical time format so it's it's a
very interesting game and I'm sure
you'll enjoy it but before that we do
have a couple of photos before we start
the game here is the photo of the bill
chess festival official photographer
Alayna totes
having a nice chat with Peter Svidler
before his game would magnus carlsen are
taken by the other official photographer
Simon bottom blue stir all of the photos
will be as usual available in the link
in the description below from the
official bill chest festival website
then here you have one of the best photo
of so far it's a photo of a gentleman
from the Beal Open tournament wearing
some sort of a hat now what kind of a
hat is it I have no idea could be some
traditional wear but whichever the case
it does look like it gives +15 to
agility so here we have a nice photo of
sailor and Carlson there's a sailor
making the first move
Carlson doesn't look very very surprised
about the first move being efore and
let's take it from here
so as we've seen Peter sailor plays
efore we have e5 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and the Bishop to b5 sorry about that
so the reuleaux PES we have a knight to
f6 the brilliant defense and now d3
seems to be the most popular
continuation nowadays Bishop to c5
Bishop captures D captures on c6 and now
Knight B to d2 Bishop to e6 Queen to e2
and the Knight to d7 now we have Knight
the b3 attacking Carlson's Bishop on c5
and now comes Bishop to b6
we have Knight to g5 attacking cousins
bishop on e6 and now you could defend it
with the queen but it's even better to
play Knight to a fate now the the Knight
is guarding the bishop nicely if if what
captured in Carson would have a nice
night on e6 but also Carson will be able
to capture the night here on b3
and then playing nine three six so
either way this night is coming to e6
although it's occupying a funny square
at the moment bush of to e3 we have
Queen to e7 now and now g3 but should
capture some b3 like we discussed a
capture some b3 and now f6 kicking the
night away Knight to f3 and only now
just cross and play tonight to e6
we have Bishop capture some b6 c capture
some b6 as the a pawn is pinned and now
sweet lord castles we have a 6 C 3 and
cross and castles Queen side rook a to
d1 we have King to be it and now Queen
the e3 attacking the b6 pawn so across
and defense that we have king to a7 and
here is fiddler played D for D for it I
mean this is a pinned point so it would
be very nice if you could attack at
somehow for example Knight d2 to c4
would be interesting but black can
easily play Queen c5 here and this will
be in blacks favor so what you can do
here if you don't want to push for
exchange like sweedler did immediately
perhaps b4 not all out this Queen to c5
move but even after black starts pushing
on the King side night to d2 preparing
Knight to c4 black will simply push and
after Knight to c4 black will go Queen
c7 defending here and again it will be a
nice position for black he already
expanded quite nicely on the King side
he was simply position his rooks and
then push even further so this would be
alright for black so instead d4
immediately by Sadler he wants to go for
the exchanges he captures on d4 Knight
captures we have Knight captures rook
captures and now h5 cousin is preparing
h4 so of course cousin doesn't want to
capture on d4 but Svidler doesn't want
to capture undef' on d8 so here rook F 1
2 d1
route capture song d4 only now does the
pawn captor seek after sandy 4 and now
h4 d 5 and now Paige characters and g3 H
captors and g3 and here Carlson played
Queen to e5 Queen to e5 is a good move
but perhaps
see captors on d5 was also playable for
example a captors on d5 Queen captures
on e3f captors on e3 and ok you have
improved this F pawn now became a
central point but now black and now
White has three point Islands and black
has two point islands so definitely in
Black's favor and although the white now
does have two central pawns you will not
be able to push this pawn alongside at
this point as the f6 pawn will be
defending it so after you bring the King
into the game let's say e for King King
c7 King G - King D six black would be
perfectly fine here and I'm pretty sure
Carlson would enjoy playing this
position so it's very peculiar why he
decided not to go for this Queen
exchange and this endgame but okay I
didn't check out the the interview as I
didn't catch the live coverage but if
any of you have and if they've commented
on it feel free to share in the comments
here cross and play the Queen to e5
probably with the idea that the B to
pawn is now attacked and perhaps you
wanted to go for the same idea after
Spiller somehow either decides to defend
the b2 upon or he wanted to see what
Svidler would do here but little played
Queen to f3 now see captors and e5 + e
captors and undie 5 will not result in a
in a queen trade so C captures he
captures and here comes Queen captures
on B to capturing the phone and Carson
is now up a pawn but Svidler now has a
very strong passed pawn so he pushes it
to d6 we have looked back a rope to d8
and now comes d7 and now it's very hard
to imagine that black could actually
achieve something here with his pawn up
as a white already has a pawn on d7
across and played Queen to c2 attacking
the rook on d1 we have looked at these
six we have Queen to c5 attacking the
rook and also adding defense to the b6
pawn queen to d1 and now Queen to a5
there's a really not all that much to do
here sweeter attacks call since Queen
rook to d5 we have Queen to e4 and now
rook to d4 Carson doesn't really have a
good Square to hide the Queen so Queen
to c6
played rook to d6 attacking cousins
Queen once again rook Queen to e4 rook
to d4 we have Queen to c6 rook to d6 and
after Queen to b4 the players agreed to
a draw or there is a three-fold
repetition on the board so you know it's
it's a draw by default so yeah that's
that's Carlsen ass wheeler versus
Carlson from round 8 of the 2018 bill
chess festival caution was not able to
you know even after the score and
Svidler will for who knows how long
keep his positive result against Magnus
Carlsen and before I forget let's check
out the standings after round 8 so
shocked their mama Dee are still in the
lead with a full point ahead of course
and six out of 18 10 miles across and
five out of eight then Peter Svidler
four and a half out of eight and Maxine
was here four out of eight an hour out
of it three and a half out of eight and
an eco gear God is one out of eight as
he did draw another game today against
David navara so tomorrow will be an epic
showdown as tomorrow Carlsen fee faces a
shocker mama Dee are of across and does
have the black pieces so it's very hard
to say what we could expect from that
and although that game will be extremely
important in deciding the outcome of the
tournament I'm sure Peter Svidler will
have a lot to say about this tournament
as well as tomorrow he faces David
navara with the black pieces so perhaps
if he does well in that game then
sweedler faces a shocker mama Dee are of
in the final round
we're sweeter we'll have the white
pieces against momma Dee are off so the
final round will be also very difficult
for for momma Dee Arav as ass wheeler is
excellent with the white pieces and as
as expected in the in the final round of
the 2018 bill chess festival course and
faces his old nemesis Nico gurgi Alice
okay now it's he's not the only one who
wasn't able to defeat him as he owes
Nico also was able to draw a game
against David navara but in the final
round course and we'll have the white
pieces against Nick ogre goddess so he
will definitely have to push for
something there so definitely gonna be
an interesting last two rounds so you
know
very happy to check it out I hope I will
catch some of the live coverage so
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and that you're enjoying the coverage of
the Beale chess festival so far I would
like to thank Jared Christopher Ballard
and Christopher the tone for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous video see I
think all for watching and I will see
you soon with of course the last two
runs of the bill chess festival but we
are tomorrow morning work normally
continuing at the Bobby Fischer story
and I would also like to thank Alan
Robert elaborate for your contribution
as I have forgotten to mention it so
thank you all and I will see you soon